- It's hot.
- [Katie] Do you like hot food?
- No.
(Kelly laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Kelly, I'm a culinary
producer here at Tasty.
- Hi, I'm Jeremy.
I'm a chef and Kelly's husband
and we have two boys
together, Dylan and Teddy.
- And we are about to
have our third this fall.
Yay!
(Kelly applauding)
- So last time we were
here, Tasty challenged us
to see who could make the
best lunch for our son, Dylan,
and I won and I've had the
bragging rights ever since.
- But today, I finally get
the chance to redeem myself
because Tasty invited us back
to see who could make the
best breakfast for Dylan.
- [Katie] Do you guys wanna
add some stakes to this?
- I think whoever wins gets
to choose the next family adventure.
I wanna go to a really
nice hotel with a pool.
- And I want to go to a punk rock concert.
- Oh, my God.
Yeah, that's our personalities.
All right, let's do it.
(Kelly and Jeremy high-fiving)
May the best man win.
(Kelly laughing)
Today, I'm making a beach
themed breakfast for Dylan.
He is a water baby.
He is a water sign.
He's always loved the beach
and I think he's really gonna love this.
So the first thing I'm
gonna make is some pancakes
and I'm gonna shape them into a sailboat.
So we have some, any milk we'll do.
This is almond milk.
That's vanilla.
A little maple syrup because you need it.
And then bananas, some oats,
and then some baking powder.
And of course, a little
salt and some eggs.
I love these pancakes
because it requires no whisk,
you can just put
everything in the blender.
It's whole ingredients.
It's super healthy and the kids love them.
(blender whirring)
- So this looks good.
And for easy pouring,
I'm just gonna put it
in a squeeze bottle just
so I can pour it easier
into the pan.
So I have a pan heating.
I'm just gonna add some butter
because you can't make a
pancake without butter.
Dylan loves pancakes, but to be honest,
I don't think I'm gonna
beat Jeremy this time.
I make the boys lunch every day,
but Jeremy really does the
breakfast in our house,
so we'll see.
So I'm gonna try to
make a pancake sailboat.
So I'm gonna make a half
circle to do the bottom.
It's cute.
I'm gonna fill it in.
I've never done pancake art before,
but I've seen it on TikTok,
so that's like college.
(Kelly laughing)
It's bubbling up top,
so I'm gonna flip it.
Hopefully, it looks good.
Hey, that's not bad.
So I'm also gonna cook
it on the other side,
probably like 30 to 60 seconds.
My little boat is done,
I'm gonna take it out.
And then I'm gonna clean
this out and make the sails.
Dylan's not really a picky
eater, he'll eat a lot of food.
He's outgrown that picky eater stage.
Our other son is in it right now.
We're just gonna let
these cook probably one
to two minutes until they're bubbling
and then flip 'em over.
My little triangles are done.
It's not as cute as I had
up here, but you know what?
As long as it tastes good.
So the next thing I'm gonna be
making is sand for the beach.
And I'm actually gonna use
scrambled eggs for that.
Crack some eggs and then a little salt.
Jeremy always makes fun of me
that this is the most annoying sound.
He's always like, "I think
you're done beating them."
I think the secret to really
good scrambled eggs is,
obviously, butter and low and slow.
I'm just gonna pour these in here.
Some people will constantly be stirring it
and that will get you really small curds.
But I actually like them to
kind of be bigger, softer,
like clouds.
These are looking perfect.
I'm gonna take them off the
heat so they stop cooking
and let's go to the next step.
So the next thing I'm making
is avocado toast palm tree.
I've never done this before,
but I need to take some bread
and cut it into the palm leaves,
and then toast it so I
can put avocado on top.
I hope this works.
I think I have to do the crust
to make it keep it shape, which is fine.
Dylan actually likes
crust, so no problem there.
Once I put the avocado on it
and it'll look like a leaf,
this is working.
Just stay with me, guys.
Just stay with me.
(Kelly laughing)
I'm just gonna pop these
in a 400 degree oven
for five to six minutes, just
until they're lightly toasted.
My toast is toasted.
Now I have to cut an
avocado to perfectly fit
on top of that bread
to make little leaves.
I'm just gonna cut it in half.
So I cut the avocado in
half and then in quarters.
And then I'm just gonna cut little slivers
to make the palm leaves.
But first, let me actually
put some lemon on it
so it doesn't brown.
So I'm gonna try to trim the toast
to the shape of the avocado.
And then I'm gonna cut some
little slits like this,
give it the palm leaf look.
Let me just season it with
some salt and then look.
So I'm gonna repeat this with the rest
of my toast and then
move on to the next step.
Now that most of my elements are done,
I'm gonna work on the final touches,
which is creating sea
creatures out of tons of fruit.
This big boy is a cantaloupe
which Dylan just started liking.
So for this one,
I found this cute little
fish cookie cutter
and I'm gonna cut out
some fish from cantaloupe.
Okay, this one worked.
Look at the little fishy.
And then I'm gonna make
a dragon fruit starfish.
Now, I don't think Dylan's
ever had this, to be honest.
I'm gonna use this starfish cookie cutter
to make some starfish.
Look how cute it is.
Things like these would drive Jeremy nuts.
He doesn't have the
patience to cut things out
of little shapes.
Maybe that's why I'm gonna win.
The next thing I'm gonna do is try
to make a turtle out of a kiwi.
So this will be our little body.
And then I gotta cut a head and some legs.
Here's our little head.
Ready to cut the little
feet so I made a circle
and then I'm just gonna
cut the circle in half
and make its little leg.
There he has four little legs.
Does it look like it?
Just to give our little
turtle friend some eyes,
mini chocolate chips.
I think he's cute.
Now I'm gonna make a
little strawberry crab.
I just cut another round for its body.
I'm just cutting little rectangles.
And then the little antennas here.
This is definitely not what I envisioned,
but we have to go with it.
And I'll just add some
chocolate chips for eyes
and, hopefully, Dylan will love it.
I think he's actually pretty cute,
so let's make our final
thing, which is a sun
which I'm gonna do is slice
an orange, and for the rays,
I'm just gonna do some dried apricots.
Dylan actually loves dried
apricots, any dried fruit really.
The last thing we have to do
is assemble it all together.
I'm actually so excited to assemble this.
I'm gonna do half savory and half sweet,
so we get a little bit of both.
For the savory side, we're
gonna do some of our eggs
as the sand.
And then for the palm tree,
I actually cooked up some maple
sausage and I'm gonna make
that to the trunk by just
stacking a few up top.
And then we have our avocado
toast for our palm leaves.
For little coconuts, we're
gonna do some blueberries,
which Dylan also loves.
For the ocean on the sweet side,
I'm gonna take some Greek yogurt
and spirulina and dye to
get that ocean blue color.
Last time, Jeremy got
eaten alive in the comments
for how much food dye he used.
So I'm trying to go the natural route,
so don't come for me.
So I'm just gonna put some
yogurt down here for our water.
Every morning we eat yogurt,
so I think this will draw him in.
And then once he tastes
everything, he'll love it.
This is his favorite
granola and I'm gonna put it
at the bottom, so it's like
the sandy bottom of the ocean.
I feel like I just wanna
make it a little more wavy.
Now we're gonna add our sailboat on top.
Now we gotta add all our sea creatures.
So we'll put a little
starfish, a little goldfish.
We got our sun.
I think this is so cute.
I honestly am not the type of mom
that does this type of stuff.
So when I do do it, it
makes me feel very happy
and excited for his reaction.
Sailboat needs windows,
so with some banana slices
on there.
This is art.
(Kelly laughing)
I feel like I should
have maybe one more fish
and another starfish.
Okay, honestly, I feel pretty good.
I'm super excited to give this to Dylan.
I think he's gonna love it.
I'm feeling really confident about this,
but Jeremy also is the breakfast king,
so I'm a little nervous to
see what he's come up with.
Let's go see.
- Today for my meal,
I will be making a monster theme breakfast
because Dylan loves monsters
and I will be starting
with monster muffins.
First of all, add our eggs.
Dylan, when it comes to breakfast,
is not a very picky eater,
but every other meal
throughout the day he is.
And next we're gonna add our oats.
We're gonna add some
cinnamon, our flaxseed.
We're gonna add one
banana and some spinach
because these are healthy muffins today.
Dylan usually doesn't eat his veggies,
so we try to find ways to sneak it
into whatever we're doing.
We're gonna add a little
green food coloring
just to brighten it up a little bit
and then blend everything together.
It's looking pretty good.
The color we want is there,
so as we're cooking it,
the color's gonna die down
a little bit in the oven.
Now we're just gonna pour
it into our muffin tins
and get ready to bake them.
I have not made these muffins
before, but based on Dylan,
I think he is going to enjoy them.
A little bit of a risk.
I don't know, after the last competition,
I got my butt kicked a little bit,
but we'll see what we can do.
So the last thing I'm gonna do is
add these little candy monster eyes
just to make them look a
little bit more like monsters.
He's been telling me for weeks now,
"I'm gonna pick you no
matter what the results are,"
so I'm feeling pretty confident today.
- [Katie] It's gonna
be a blind taste test.
- I know, that's the one part
I'm worried about is the blind taste test.
And now we're gonna bake
these at 350 degrees
for about 20 minutes.
While the muffins are in the oven,
we're gonna move on to
our monster face paninis.
So first, we're gonna crack our eggs.
I am the king of breakfast,
which is why I normally don't need
to use these little tricks.
But today I'll do what I have to do.
So we're just gonna add a
little butter to our pan,
whisk our eggs until
they're nice and light.
I do use a lot of butter in breakfast.
It's the most important meal of the day.
Now the butter's nice and
melted, we're just gonna add
in our eggs and keep them
moving to make them nice
and fluffy as they cook.
So I'm just making the egg into a square
to make it fit nicely onto
the bread for our panini.
Just give it a nice little flip
and the eggs are ready for the panini.
We're just gonna take
our two pieces of bread
and we're gonna start building our panini.
So we're gonna add our egg.
Now, our egg's on the bread,
we're gonna add a few pieces
of bacon, already have some
cooked bacon ready to go.
And then we're gonna top our bacon
with a little bit of cheddar cheese.
Dylan loves cheese, he is always looking
for the perfect cheese pull.
Our sandwich is ready to go
and next step is we're gonna
grill it on the panini press.
So first we're gonna spray our press.
And now we're gonna add our sandwich.
We're gonna cook this
for about two minutes
until it's golden brown and crispy.
All right, now that our
sandwich is golden brown
and ready to go, we're gonna
take it off the panini press
and start building our monster face.
First thing we're gonna do
for the monster face is cut out circles
of Canadian bacon for the eyes.
I don't think Dylan's ever
had Canadian bacon before,
so it's another risk I'm gonna
take, but it's delicious,
so can't go wrong with it.
Now we're just gonna cut little
slices in our Canadian bacon
so we could pop the hard
boiled egg eyes through.
Now, this is the part I'm
worried about the most
'cause I don't think Dylan
likes hard boiled eggs,
but we are going to find out today.
The eyes look okay,
I think what gives eyes
expression is the eyebrows,
so once I add some angry
eyebrows onto there,
I think they'll look a little better.
I think the eyebrows give
them a little more expression.
Next, we are going to
cut a red bell pepper
for the mouth and we're
just going to slice it
into little strips and
then make it nice and spiky
so it looks like teeth.
And now we have our little mouth.
Last thing I'm gonna do
is slice a few pieces
of kiwi just for the arms and legs
so it looks like a scary monster.
What do you think?
That's a scary sandwich.
Now that we're finished with our panini,
we're gonna check back
in with our muffins.
Now that our muffins are out of the oven,
we're going to fill them with Nutella
just to give them a special little treat.
Dylan does have a little sweet tooth,
but normally not in actual meals.
Now that our muffins are
done, we're gonna move on
to our next step, which
is a fruit smoothie.
So first we're gonna
add some frozen peaches,
some frozen banana, frozen
chunks of pineapple,
and two big handfuls of spinach.
Dylan will usually take about three sips
of my breakfast smoothie every morning.
So I know he'll like it,
especially with the green color,
green is his favorite color.
And now I'm just gonna add a little bit
of coconut milk to blend it all together
and make a nice smoothie.
All right, now that our
smoothie is all blended
and good to go, we are going to pour it
into our glass and get
our garnishes ready.
I chose this smoothie because
every Sunday morning we go
to the farmer's market as a family.
The first stop at the farmer's
market is I get a green juice
for myself and I might get two sips
in before Dylan finishes
the rest of my green juice.
Now that our smoothie is in our glass,
we are going to garnish it
with little eyes made out
of bananas and blueberry.
So we're just gonna poke a
little hole in the banana
with a glass straw so we could
fit our blueberry in there.
We have our little eyeball.
Now that I have some skewers,
I cut them down to size
and they'll fit perfectly in our glass.
And there is our monster berry smoothie.
I feel really good about this one.
I think this might be his favorite part
of the entire breakfast.
So the last thing we're gonna make is
some fun fruit monsters.
So we're just gonna make
a little monster mouth.
We're gonna cut our apple into slices.
Next, we're gonna spread
a little almond butter
inside the apple, gonna
put these two together.
And now we're just gonna put
in some yogurt-covered raisins
to look like little monster teeth.
For the monster's eyes, we're
gonna put some marshmallows
on toothpicks with little
chocolate chips in the middle,
and that'll also help it hold
the whole thing together.
Now we have a monster mouth.
Next, we are gonna make a monster kiwi.
It's mostly eyes and
teeth in making monsters.
There's not much of an art to it.
It's just try to make it look
as fun and scary as you can.
We're gonna do a few slices of kiwi.
We're just gonna take
our first slice of kiwi.
Put a little slice of strawberry
in the middle to make a little tongue.
And now we're gonna take our toothpick.
We're gonna add our
marshmallows and chocolate chips
to make our eyes for this little monster.
Toothpicks are pretty
dangerous around our kids,
so you have to be a little careful
when making monsters outta food.
And now we have our kiwi monster.
For our last monster,
we're going to do orange
with some blueberry arms and
legs and a pineapple Mohawk.
And he does love Mohawks.
I'm just taking blueberries
and putting them onto a toothpick
and then putting the
toothpick into the orange.
So now we have the body for our monster
and we're going to make
a little pineapple Mohawk
and stick that in.
And for the monster's eyeball,
since it's not related to
the chocolate chip monsters,
we are going to use a raisin for the eye.
Now that our monsters are assembled,
I'm gonna get everything
together and assemble our plate.
So first thing we're gonna
do is move our sandwich over.
That's gonna be the
centerpiece of our plate
with its little kiwi arms and legs.
Next we're gonna add our scariest muffin.
Now we're gonna put our
smoothie on the plate
and I'm gonna try to stand up the cyclops.
Now we'll add our little fruit monsters
and breakfast is served.
It is a real monster party for breakfast.
I feel good.
I think I do have a chance
at redemption today.
Now let's go see what Dylan thinks.
Better not let me down.
- [Woman] And open.
(Dylan chuckling)
(Kelly laughing)
- Monsters?
Green's my favorite color.
I'm gonna try this first.
I like it.
The alien, I like Mohawks.
I like the blueberries.
I taste bacon and eggs.
He looks funny.
I think it's chocolate inside.
- [Katie] What's your
favorite thing you've eaten?
- The blueberries.
(Kelly laughing)
I like this for breakfast.
Please bring in the next dish.
- [Katie] All right, and open your eyes.
- Wow!
It's the beach.
I like the other one,
but I don't know what this tastes like.
It tastes like candy.
There's a boat on it.
I don't really like the pancakes.
I like the fish.
Eggs!
I like it.
It's decision time!
- Did you like the ocean
plate or the monster plate?
- Monster.
(Kelly and Jeremy applauding)
- Whoo!
- Daddy won!
- Good job, dad.
- Thanks, dude.
- Good job, Dylan, and great job, Jeremy.
I guess we're tied now.
Thanks so much for watching
and we'll see you next time.
Bye!
Say bye.
- Bye!
- [Man] Oh, yes!
(upbeat music)